an horrific Massacre this was the scene
after Israel targeted Palestinians
traveling on the al- rashed
highway the major Road Links the
Northern parts of the strip to the South
it's the main road families are using to
flee the Israeli bombardment of Gaza
City and the surrounding
areas but the South isn't safe either in
cunas this community is stuck in a
NeverEnding cycle of death and devast
station day and night more injured
people arrive at already overwhelmed
hospitals there is no let up in Israeli
strikes on densely populated areas with
no fuel for his car this Palestinian
doctor rides his bike between makeshift
shelters to treat his
patients one of the obstacles is the
road itself sometimes there's a
bombardment and the road is damaged so I
have to carry the bicycle on my
shoulders and walk some of the distance
until I'm past the rubble and
destruction gaza's healthcare system is
on the verge of collapse no fuel and
shortages of medicine and basic hospital
supplies the entire Healthcare sector in
Gaza Strip is reduced to four hospitals
even those four hospitals are under
imminent threat because they're
partially out of service due to lack of
fuel and consequently
power while a limited number of people
have been able to leave Gaza via the
rougher Crossing others have been forced
to return Israeli authorities deported
thousands of Palestinian workers who had
been detained in Israel their work
permits were revoked after Hamas
launched its attack on Southern
Israel the workers say they were held in
harsh conditions one man said they were
treated like
animals the police arrested workers one
by one they blindfolded and handcuffed
us for 2 days we slept on the ground
unaware of what was happening without
any food or
water they may be free now but these
Palestinians have little to celebrate
forced to return to Gaza where their
homes May no longer be standing and
their families displaced or Worse killed
Jessica Washington Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer